voir les caducée au vestiaire ou comme
l'écrivait certains de mes confrères
aujourd'hui demain éviter d'être malade
demain en effet les français devront
faire face à une grève inhabituelle
celle des médecins leurs cabinets seront
fermés dans 90% des cas seules les
urgences seront assurées
je précise que les hôpitaux aussi
fonctionne les médecins ne proteste pas
seulement contre le blocage de leurs
honoraires mais aussi contre les projets
du gouvernement destiné à résorber le
déficit de la sécurité sociale
la grève de demain été lancée par la
puissante confédération des syndicats
médicaux qui propose une véritable
conférence nationale sur la santé
la fédération des médecins de france des
médecins de france s'est associée à ce
mouvement et son président nous explique
pourquoi
a situation économique globale il faudra
l'examen du bilan global c'est-à-dire
que très rapidement les partenaires
intéressés se réunissent pour faire une
étude du bilan de la sécurité sociale
dans sa totalité et pas seulement sur la
médecine de ville c'est à dire revoir
certaines couvertures certaine prise en
charge indue ou excessive de la sécurité
sociale voulez vous un exemple quand on
a sorti la loi sur l'avortement que je
ne remets pas en cause
en même temps on a parlé contraception
et on n'a fait qu'ouvrir par la sécurité
sociale toutes les dépenses de
contraception jeu je n'exposerai pas mon
mot position de médecins en tant que
citoyens j'en ai eu une en tant que lieu
de ça je ne vois aucun inconvénient
mais il est évident que la contraception
ce n'est pas de la maladie et il y à
bien d'autres bien d'autres pas comme
cela il y a par exemple on a pris les
handicapés physiques
on les a mis au compte de l'assurance
maladie alors que c'est la nation qui
doit les prendre en compte
il faut revoir les fonctionnements de
l'hospitalisation en particulier de
nominations publiques au niveau de sa
gestion
il faut revoir aussi la médecine de
ville et sur ce point les médecins sont
tout à fait d'accord pour étudier avec
leurs plats avec leurs partenaires le
fonctionnement de cette médecine ils
l'ont d'ailleurs prouvé en acceptant que
le fonctionnement de leur fac e là le
comportements médicale des médecins soit
étudiée dans le cadre des profils il
accepte pour les revoit et qu'on discute
là dessus mais ils ne veulent pas si
vous voulez que seuls ils soient
concernés dans cette affaire est que à
partir d'une erreur de jugement
ce soit les malades qui soigne en quoi
l'intérêt des maladies soient mieux